hair are you okay bad excuse me I'm a
joke okay Oh than that so a lot of you
are pissed about piss queue opening
title sequence reading with grace it's
writing with grace cuz I really don't
want to write this whole thing by myself
it's writing with grace writing with me
me my name is Grace you guys submitted
your entries for chapter 4 in which it's
day 4 freak week there is no gravity not
only does it affect your physical person
it affects your emotion everything is up
in the air and at least 10% of you
included in your entry some sort of
concern for how to pee with no gravity
and to that I'd like to say thank you
for really exposing a fear I have
terrifying speaking of you peeing you're
peeing European Europe I was just in
Europe and now I'm in New York which is
why I'm not in my normal ready with
grace set up now let's get into some I
swear them very silly here's a stat at
least 20 of you have submitted chapters
every single week of this series and
thank you we see you do not think we
don't and this is not meant to be
threatening even though there's a
pointing finger this is meant to be like
a gentle like thanks we see you at least
one of you participated in our steps to
enjoy my week proof whoa
hey here's the stat I spent six days in
the Arctic last week searching for those
penguins that have yet to submit to
writing with race here's proof
it was a long six days but boy did I get
some good cardio in now on just
something like superlatives for the week
this dialogue goes to a song of songs
mmm
how could somebody even do this lace
wondered aloud the world is full of
cruelty and injustice who are we to
understand the nature of no banana I
mean physically how could someone send a
message to the whole school oh they
probably hack the Wi-Fi or something mr.
Kevin laughs sharply can't trust the
Wi-Fi can't trust your wife probably
can't trust waffles either and there
went the waterworks everyone pretended
not to notice too real very good job
Anna poor banana is now planting people
I have something to tell you when I
chose the name banana I thought it fit
me perfectly and I was happy with it but
I realized it wasn't right a while ago
and I didn't know how to tell people I
thought it would be banana forever but
time passed and I realized another name
fit me better so I'd like to be called
plantain she stopped talking and relaxed
slowly falling backwards got me good
now it's a prom price it goes to use her
fancy dressing who created this really
amazing sequence of a zero-gravity trial
they're having this like courtroom drama
of accusing each other but they're all
in zero gravity because it's day for a
freak week and it's just it's very well
done some would say it's very moving I
also wanna shout out user love words who
created an animated mass of Great Wave a
school that they added into their
submission very cool is your chosen Jeff
the chapter lamp chosen for chapter 4
goes to Diane's not here for a week
drumroll that's not the same
it goes to user Sarah Rose wheeler who
is one of those 20 people that has been
submitting a chapter every single week
of this process so congratulations Sarah
Rose wheeler this week goes to you in
your chapter when Harry Met lace I
thought you did an amazing job using the
prompt that day for is zero gravity
meaning your physical body is up in the
air and all of your emotional
insecurities starts coming out turn a
moment between Harry and lace whether by
themselves and Harry just bursts out
that he's in love with Marmee oh my god
just let you guys in on a little secret
I really really hope that that would
happen
I'm very invested in fictional
characters also I'm very very much [ __ ]
Harry and Marv me har me so good but
their other ship name could be Mary M
Arry
okay here's the deal Harmeet or Mary I'm
creating a poll on Twitter and you guys
go over to my Twitter account right now
and vote are you for ship Harvey or ship
Mary oh my god okay get it together or
don't also in this chess we find out
that Harry is innocent because of his
dumb Ness he admits that he doesn't even
know how to spell Wi-Fi how would he be
able to hack into the Wi-Fi so he is off
the hook until he hooks up with Marmee
hey take me seriously cause I love that
lace and Harry are having this moment
together because there are two people
that normally don't really like each
other and because of freak week they're
bonding over lo because lace also tells
Harry how much she loves crush and then
it turns into this like high schools
girls sleepover gossip session moment
where they both reveal so much of
themselves and then they end up like
hugging and crying and becoming misfits
it's so much but it's also not enough
and at the very end of the chapter
this mysterious robotic voice comes over
the speaker system of the school and
says I know what but before you can even
process that voice both Harry and Lise
receive a text message that is a
screenshot of a private text
conversation that lace and banana were
having in which lace tells banana how
much she likes crush and banana comfort
sir and thinks that there they could be
great together and hairy because he
receives at the same time as lace the
chapter ends with them questioning if
you can read that text can everyone read
this text so kudos to you Sarah Rose
wheeler I think it's a wonderful
wonderful chapter and a great addition
to the overall freak we think it's
coming together pretty nicely you guys
how are you enjoying it so far
remember this is all gonna get read on
stage at VidCon so these chapters
I'm just already imagining how fun
they're gonna be to read out loud with a
group of mysterious readers at VidCon so
keep that in mind when you're writing by
the way drops Chapter five
here are the prompts for next week's
chapter I love the way this chapter four
ended so much that I have decided that
yes everyone in their group has in fact
seen the screenshot of message of lace
professing her love for crush and
because this mysterious voice is
threatening them if they try to fix the
Wi-Fi they will now communicate only in
text message
did you see that coming if you did you
were lying Congrats on that human
quality you have maybe that seems like a
little overwhelming to write that way
but I've decided to give you the
beginning of chapter 5 just to get you
started
chapter 5 will begin like this banana
oops sorry lace didn't mean to send that
screech out to everyone but we should
all talk through group text so we're not
over her by that gender-neutral voice
from the loudspeaker I think it's mr.
Kevin he must be the hacker I left mr.
Kevin out of this text crush great idea
mr. Kevin oh my god I've never been on
group text before am i doing it right la
la la la la mr. Kevin wait you think I'm
the hackers wall banana dang it I can't
help but be inclusive even when I don't
want to be starting a new group text
sorry mr. K mr. Kevin oh my god sad face
so that's all chapter 5 will begin and
now it's up to you to continue the
chapter with these prompts one chapter
five has to continue in text messages
and the only other prompt is that you
could decide what happens day five a
freak week what is the environmental
thing that shakes everything up also
side note remember no brands no bad
words no banging like intense sexual
thanks don't forget to submit by this
Sunday via Wattpad and when you submit
via Wattpad make sure that you're
creating a new story for each chapter
and hashtagging it writing with grace so
we can find it read it go like ah at it
and then also go huh whoa at it again
thank you guys so much for participating
in this series this has been so much fun
I really love the way freak week is
turning out so far and I hope you do too
I'm excited for your chapter five
submissions especially because I have no
idea what is happening day five a freak
week it can be anything anything
anything oh my god I got lots of
thoughts thinking about tacos can you
see those notes yeah I'll see you guys
you know like everyday
on the internet I don't know